what's the most important part of the
screenwriting process that if it was
taken away it would just totally make
the whole thing you know not fun it
would negate the whole process way for
me for me the most important part of the
process I guess is all I mean the most
important part of any process of writing
whether to scream or not is the dreaming
you know the dreaming of making another
world or telling a new fresh story I
don't know if that's particular to
screenwriting but again I do like the
cinematic format of a screenplay I'm not
going to say that I prefer it to a novel
or a book but there is a media see to it
and I guess if screenplays didn't have
that immediacy maybe I wouldn't be it's
attracted to writing it but I like that
kind of you know that sort of I guess
Hunter s Thompson sort of like really
rapid-fire way that you can write a
script
not everyone writes screenplays like
that you know some people like
Manchester by the sea I'm sure isn't
written that way you know it's a you
know it's a slow slow drive and it's
suggested to the characters or subtly
and beautifully you know and and there's
there there's different gears you can
you can use to write a screenplay and
and sometimes you want to write a slow
one and sometimes you want to write a
fast one and that's that's I think part
of the fun is there a specific book that
you've enjoyed reading that's touch
about the writing process or maybe
indirectly talk to you about it that's
not really intended for screenwriters
well I didn't I read a Syd field book
when I started out and I had read it and
I liked some of what he had to say and I
read how did be asked whatever some book
you know for dummies or something happy
that that didn't do anything for me once
in a while these books work when they
tell you things to avoid I think those
when you when you get asked when you're
the
store you're gonna see 75 books to say
how to be a screenwriter I would say the
most valuable aspect of those books are
are often the parts where they tell you
to avoid things they say stay away from
you know because there are cliches there
are a lot of them and when people in the
film industry read those cliches over
and over again you know they it has an
effect on them my I got my experience
from reading my favorite movies or my
favorite screenplays so I and I remember
when I opened up Sid fields book I think
his first one he was talking about
Chinatown and he's talking about how he
thinks it might be one of the best or
the best screenplay of the 1970s he said
and I had just at that time gotten into
Chinatown I'd watched it like eight
times in a row I was you know whatever I
was 18 years old I had just really
discovered it and I loved it it's what
made me want to be a screenwriter and
then to see him say that in his prologue
I was like oh okay I mean I want to be
on this guys and I read Chinatown I read
I remember I read a Shawshank Redemption
and American Beauty and well I wanted to
read American Beauty because a lot maybe
people don't know this but it has a
whole different ending in the movie you
know I wanted to read the shooting
screenplays and see how different they
were from the the the actual movie I
read I got a lot of information I felt
from him from a script from the
screenplay for the People vs Larry Flynt
reason being that was based on a true
story obviously Larry Flynt I think had
eight wives and in the movie there's
just Courtney Love and that was just
revelation to me you know that you can
in order to make a movie work in a
certain time period here's how you can
cheat the numbers and still be mostly
true that was obviously a big cheat but
the People vs Larry Flynt I remember
what and Shawshank were big ones for me
for
a lot about the the formatting of the
script and you know how much action and
how little action you need when you when
you're at your heading and things like
that the formatting is very important
you know the aesthetic is very important
and I basically learned by reading
screenplays
you